via mavattam Natalie of course we expect
reliability and the adherence to
international agreements that have been
achieved with the help of the United
States schema climate treaty has to
remain in force and his development must
continue and of course the agreement
with Iran as well it was neither these
are all agreements that were achieved in
cooperation with the Obama
administration reliability will be a
major task for the trump presidency
about NYC I believe he's a pretty
uncultured person who will try to run
the United States like a large
corporation which is not possible and
will be a failure I think he has little
interest in foreign policy which could
have serious consequences especially if
it promotes isolation itself up short on
the aversion antrim vehement of course
we expect that everything that Trump has
announced everything that is divisive
and discriminates that drives a wedge
into society his treatment of the media
that all of that will not be turned into
reality in his actual program of
government jets enzyme wigwams would
abide spocom was are the united states
are a democracy with a long history
which was always demonstrated as powers
of self-defense so I would say Donald
Trump has been elected but the
Constitution has not been cancelled to
add nizhny up give it one